hello
my name is brad dietzen i'm a senior
here at hillsdale college and i'm
majoring in politics
and i have the privilege to introduce
you mr elliott abrams
elliott abrams served in the state
department during all eight years
of ronald reagan's presidency mr abrams
who received his ba from harvard college
a master's degree
in international relations from the
london school of economics
and his jd from the harvard school law
school
also held senior foreign policy
positions in the administration
of president george w bush he also
has been a senior fellow at the hudson
institute and served as president of the
ethics and public policy center
he is a recipient of the secretary of
state's distinguished service award
for his work in the reagan
administration he has appeared on
meet the press face the nation nightline
and most major television news programs
his articles
and book reviews have appeared in
commentary the weekly standard
the national interest and national
review he is the author
or editor of several books including
close calls intervention terrorism
missile defense and just war today
please join me in welcoming mr elliott
abrams
thank you
brad thank you for that uh very kind
introduction i'm just taking my watch
off to set it down here because there's
no clock we could be here for hours if i
don't
watch this it really is a great pleasure
to uh
to be here at hillsdale and to
participate in this centenary
retrospective
on president reagan in 1980 i was one of
a group of then
democrats who switched party
to support ronald reagan in that year's
election
and who then joined the reagan
administration
and as brad said i had the honor of
serving all
eight years in getting to work
with president reagan now the
the topic for tonight is ronald reagan
and the
the end of the cold war and
i realize that when we talk about the
cold war and even
the end of the cold war
we're talking about a period when
just about every student at hillsdale
and really at any college
was not yet born
the controversy over reagan's role
in the end of the cold war how much
credit does he get
for any of the cold war and for bringing
down the soviet union
i realize must seem to some students
a little bit like a dispute over um how
did the napoleonic wars
end or how did world war one
start i realize that's not true for a
large
portion of the audience who remain
remembers it very well as i do
but i think it's important to start back
not just for the students but for all of
us
to start back and ask what did the world
look like before
ronald reagan became president
that is you need to understand we all
need to remember
what reagan saw when he decided to run
for president
in the late 70s and
even what he saw in the 60s what he
saw was american
decline here are just
some examples of what he saw
in 1968 north korea
attacked a u.s navy ship the uss pueblo
in international waters
and held the crew of american sailors
hostage for 11 months during which they
were
frequently beaten and sometimes
tortured 11 months they were finally
returned to the united states after
we apologized for this incident
in 1973 came the middle east war
a coalition of arab countries attacked
israel the united states
rushed arms to israel to prevent its
defeat
the soviet union backed the arabs and
told us
to stay out
such was the state of our alliances
in 1973 that in all
of nato in all of nato
one country portugal
was willing to allow us overflight
rights
so that our planes could get to the
middle east
by the shortest most direct group all
the others
stood by just watched the u.s russia
confrontation didn't want to
side with the united states in 1975
came the end of the vietnam war not
of course with a victory
nor with a tie but
with a clear american defeat
the fall of saigon the capital of south
vietnam
in 1975 and 1976
communist cuba sent an expeditionary
force of
35 000 troops to africa
to help the communist guerrillas
in angola wind power
there 1979
was the year before the election of
course
and it was the worst year of all
in march of that year leftist forces
launched a coup against the government
of grenada
tiny island in the caribbean
they took over they immediately declared
their desire
to follow the cuban model and they
established what they called
the people's revolutionary government of
grenada
they suspended the constitution
they immediately started building an
army
one that had the ability to intervene in
neighboring islands
with cuban help that's march in july
1979 communist guerrilla forces
known as the sandinistas took over
nicaragua so
for the first time since 1959 20 years
later
1979 communists had won control
of a country in our neighborhood
but this time it was two countries and
one nicaragua
was on the mainland and easily capable
of doing what the sandinistas said they
wanted to do which was to export
revolution
to guatemala el salvador costa rica
and honduras then in december 1979
began the soviet invasion of afghanistan
where they ultimately sent 100 000
troops and about 2 000 tanks
our enemy in the cold war the soviet
union was on the move
and in the face of all this the carter
administration seemed
paralyzed president carter and in fact
president carter had delivered a famous
speech in 1977 where he said
quote we are now free of that inordinate
fear of communism
once led us to embrace any dictator who
joined us in that fear
close quote so what did that mean
go back to nicaragua when the government
of the dictator and he was the dictators
anastasiosomozo was falling
and the sandinistas linked to cuba
and the soviets looked like they were
ready to jump in to fill
any vacuum that would be created
president carter was urged to stop them
do something push samosa out
establish a decent centrist government
a moderate government that would replace
him
and stay off the sandinistas
his president carter's chief advisor on
latin american affairs
said quote i felt that carter should not
overthrow a government i felt that we
were in that business too long
and it was time to get out of that
business regardless
of what the circumstances were close
quote
better in this view in the carter view
better to do nothing and see a communist
regime established instead of a
democratic one
just don't use american power
we're out of that business
by the way i should just say as we see
the soviet rise
not everyone thought the soviet union
was going to emerge as the dominant
power in the world
that was the year 1979 when a famous
professor of asian studies at harvard
wrote a book entitled japan as number
one
we were not number one
but i skipped over something that
happened in november
1979 that was really
the worst incident in that awful year
on november 4th 1979
52 americans were
seized in iran by its new
revolutionary regime under the ayatollah
khomeini they overran
our embassy in tehran and took the staff
there
hostage ultimately those people were
held
in captivity for 444 days
in tehran ultimately they were
released when were they released
it is as the russians used to say it is
not a coincidence comrade
they were released on january 20th 1981
the day that ronald reagan was
inaugurated as president
there was by the way during their
captivity an effort to
rescue them in april 1980 but
it was a disastrous failure eight
american soldiers died trying to rescue
them
no one was rescued and american prestige
sank even lower so
that is what the world looked like at
the end of the 1970s and into
1980 american decline
was widely believed and of course in
some places it was
welcomed the great british
author paul johnson in his book
modern times wrote that on the way to
defeat in vietnam the united states
agreed to
16 bombing pauses and 72
peace initiatives paul johnson wrote
that these were quote
interpreted by friend and foe alike as
evidence not of humanity but of guilt
and lack of righteous conviction
johnson called the scene of american
forces running from
saigon quote the gravest
and most humiliating defeat in american
history and he wrote that
this had a real impact on the leadership
of the soviet union
soviet leaders believed there was a
quote deepening
general crisis in the united states
in exactly this period there was a
conversation between the man who was
chief of naval
operations admiral zumwalt and secretary
of state
then henry kissinger where kissinger
said to the admiral
the united states has quote passed its
high point
like so many other civilizations
paul johnson wrote that america's
decline
in the 1970s seemed even more
precipitous in contrast with the
apparent
solidity and self-confidence
of the soviet regime
in modern times he records that as early
as 1971
a decade before really the soviet union
had more
nuclear missiles than we did between
1962 and 1977 15 years
we built 302 navy ships
302 and the russians built 1300
and while they were growing in military
power
they were also expanding directly or
through proxies in the third world i've
mentioned grenada afghanistan nicaragua
angola but the list is actually longer
between 1974 and 1980
south vietnam cambodia laos south yemen
mozambique also came under communist
domination that's 10 countries
in six years they were really on a roll
it looked
you know it looked like it looked like
we were losing
it was a reminder of the words of the
author whitaker chambers richard
chambers who in the 1930s and 40s had
been a
spy for the soviet union
until he broke with communism in 1948
and ultimately
became a great friend of william f
buckley
and was one of the early authors writing
for national review
magazine but when he left the communist
party in 1948 he told his wife
chambers told his wife quote i know
that i am leaving the winning side for
the losing side by 1980 it looked
to many people like we were still the
losing side
in the cold war with the soviet union
now i say all of this because i think we
need to understand
the first thing ronald reagan did to end
the cold war
the first thing was to believe and to
say
that it was a war it was still
continuing
and that the united states had the
ability to reverse
our fortunes
dick allen richard allen was a long-time
advisor to
president reagan and when
ronald reagan became president dick
allen was named his first national
security adviser
and i want to read you two stories dick
allen tells about
who was ronald reagan what did he think
here's dick allen the first story
says in january 1977 i visited
ronald reagan in los angeles and during
our four-hour conversation he said many
memorable things but none more
significant than this
he said quote my idea of american policy
toward the soviet union is
simple and some would say simplistic he
said
it is this we win and they lose
and and he said to dick allen what do
you think of that
and dick allen writes you know no one
had ever heard such words from the lips
of a major
political figure until then we had only
thought in terms of
managing and coping with the
relationship with the soviet union
second story from dick allen there was
an obvious need he says for the governor
governor reagan to embark on foreign
travel
so following an april 1978 trip to east
asia
reagan visited europe britain france and
germany
in november 78 it was in berlin at the
tail end of this trip
that reagan experienced a powerful
first-hand encounter with
the face of communism approaching the
berlin wall
his countenance darkened and he stood
before
it in silence for several minutes before
turning and saying
we have got to find a way to knock this
thing
down nine years later as president he
would utter
those historic words standing in the
same place mr gorbachev tear down
this wall now what we see in those
stories was reagan's
faith in america and his you know he
used the word simple and i will use it
his
simple refusal to accept
the idea of american decline so
without his background how did he win
the cold war
i think there are three parts to this he
understood
that the soviet military buildup
particularly in nuclear weapons and in
the third world would have to be
countered and that we'd have to show
them they could
never possibly defeat us militarily or
even keep up with us that's first second
he understood that the cold war was also
an ideological war and that he would
need to
attack communism
and be a kind of prophet of freedom
he put it this way in his first
inaugural address
no weapon in the arsenals of the world
is so formidable
as the will and moral courage of free
men and women
that second third he believed in america
he did not believe
in american decline and he understood
how to communicate
that to americans so i want to take
each of those for just a few minutes
well let's take the military side first
in 1980 the u.s defense budget
was 303 billion 303
in his last year in office it was 426
billion dollars
it's more than a one-third increase
when he came into office as president
the united states navy had 530
naval vessels in his eight years in
president
as president he built 60 more
so under him first of all the american
military was clearly not under any kind
of decline
and that's just the numbers there's also
the technology which was far superior
of course to anything the soviets could
even understand
and then there was star wars some of you
will remember star wars this was missile
defense the strategic
defense initiative
mrs thatcher later recalled the moment
she said
do you remember how much they mocked an
old man's obsession with star wars
well now we know from the mouths of
ex-soviet officials no less
that the strategic defense initiative
was crucial in forcing them
to renounce military competition and to
end
the cold war close quote the fact was
that
as we built missile defense it was going
to make the huge soviet investment
in missiles obsolete
and keeping up with american technology
was just going to bankrupt
them and increasingly they knew it
the vatican secretary stayed in those
years with cardinal cassaroli and he
later said ronald reagan obligated
the soviet union to increase its
military spending to the limits
of insupportability
but reagan knew he needed to do more
than just build up the forces
he needed to stop that soviet expansion
in the third world
so he did in 1983
the united states invaded grenada
unseated
the leftist government and set it on a
democratic course and here we are in
2011
and it is still a democracy in nicaragua
he backed
the so-called contras the antecedent and
easter rebels in a civil war that tied
their hands
and by 1990 forced them to hold a free
election that
they lost next door was
el salvador where it really looked like
another communist victory was imminent
when i entered the reagan administration
in 1980
nicaragua had been lost our main concern
at that moment was
are we going to lose another domino is
el salvador going to go
under communist control so reagan
organized aid for the salvadoran
military and the christian democratic
party
stopped the communist rebels the fmln
pushed them toward free elections which
they held
under fire 2011 el salvador
remains in democracy to this day in
angola he negotiated the departure of
the cuban troops
in afghanistan he supplied anti-soviet
rebels with arms
and in the end the russians suffered 15
thousand
killed they admitted defeat
in 1988 and they were out by 1989
and near the heart of the soviet empire
was poland
reagan acted to help the solidarity
movement survive
and ultimately prevail in 1980 and 81
solidarity was growing gaining influence
gaining popularity
under its leader lek valensa so the
soviets decided to crush it
and they sent tanks to the borders of
poland
martial law was declared in december
tanks rolled in the streets of warsaw
reagan began the secret
funding of solidarity working with the
afl-cio under george meaney working with
the vatican
under a polish pope and solidarity's
voice was not silenced
by 1999 the communists were forced to
negotiate with solidarity
a free election was held communist party
of course lost
and in 1990 just about a year after
reagan leaves office
elect valencia is elected president of
poland
so reagan used american power and
influence to stop
the soviet juggernaut he did it
carefully
with minimal american casualties
margaret thatcher once said quote ronald
reagan
won the cold war without firing a shot
that's an exaggeration but it's not a
great exaggeration
reagan used intelligence assets when he
quit cia
he strengthened our broadcasting voice
of america radio for europe used that
he used proxy forces like the nicaraguan
contras
whenever possible rather than american
soldiers
but the outcome the outcome was clear
in sheer military terms
he turned things around no one no one
after reagan could believe
the soviets were going to beat us
militarily
no one could believe they were pulling
ahead of us no one could believe they
were taking over
the third world that's first the second
part was the
of his way of ending the cold war was
his ideological
assault on communism
it's hard to explain how extraordinary
that was
but recall president carter was talking
about getting over
our inordinate fear of communism reagan
had a different message in a speech at
notre dame in 1981 he said quote
the west won't contain communism
it will transcend communism it will
dismiss it
as some bizarre chapter in human history
whose last pages are even now being
written
that was amazing rhetoric and he went
further
1983 spoke to the national association
of evangelicals
this was a moment when many clergy in
the us were backing a thing called the
nuclear freeze
that meant we shouldn't build another
missile
we shouldn't build another nuclear
weapon freeze no matter what the soviets
did
we freeze here's what reagan said to the
national association of evangelicals at
a time when
so many in the american clergy
were backing the nuclear freeze he said
in your discussions of the nuclear
freeze proposals i urge you to beware
the temptation of pride the temptation
of blithely declaring yourselves
above it all and labeling both sides
equally at fault to ignore the facts of
history
and the aggressive impulses
of an evil empire to simply call the
arms race a giant misunderstanding and
thereby remove
yourself from the struggle between right
and wrong
and good and evil close quote now reagan
was
attacked he was mocked for using that
phrase
evil empire in the new york times the
leading columnist of the day
anthony lewis called reagan's speech
quote simplistic sectarian
dangerous outrageous and primitive
close quote reagan of course never
backed away from those words
because it was an evil empire
it's hard to explain
how shocking how remarkable it was to
have an american president
saying those things but i think there's
a way i can convey it
that's by telling you what natan
sharonsky said who was sharonsky
sharonski is now the head of the jewish
agency in israel but he was born in
russia
and he was jailed by the soviets for
a terrible crime teaching hebrew
he was a leader of a group known then as
the refusenix
these were russian jews who were trying
to emigrate to israel men and women who
wanted to
move there and they were refused a an
exit permit
by the soviet union had to have an exit
permit
and many of them were prison in
siberia as sharansky was nine years
nine years in siberia
when president reagan died sharansky was
asked quote were there any particular
reagan moments that you can recall being
sources of strength or encouragement to
you
and your fellow prisoners and here's
sharansky's answer
i have to laugh people who take freedom
for granted
who take ronald reagan for granted
always ask such questions
of course it was the great
brilliant moment when we learned that
ronald reagan had proclaimed
the soviet union and evil empire before
the entire world
there was a long list of all the western
leaders who had lined up
to condemn the evil reagan for daring to
call the great soviet union
an evil empire right next to the front
page story about this
dangerous terrible man who wanted to
take back the world back to the dark
days of the cold war
this sharansky continues this was the
moment
it was the brightest most glorious day
finally a spade had been called a spade
president reagan had from that moment
made it impossible
for anyone in the west to continue
closing their eyes to the real nature of
the soviet union
it was one of the most important freedom
affirming declarations
and we all and he means here his fellow
prisoners in siberia
we all instantly knew it for us that was
the moment
that really marked the end for them
and the beginning for us the lie had
been exposed
and could never ever be untold now
this was the end of lenin's great
october bolshevik revolution
and the beginning of a new revolution a
freedom revolution
reagan's revolution close quote
reagan understood what his critics did
not
that the soviet union was based on a
great lie
and that the people who lived there
could not expose it it was
too dangerous for them except for a very
courageous view
like sharansky we had to expose it
not make believe we were blind to the
struggle or above it or too
sophisticated to take
a moral position reagan not only did
this in speeches he did it face to face
when he met gorbachev in 1985 he said to
him
what you are doing in afghanistan is
burning villages
and killing children it is genocide and
you
must stop it needless to say there was
no one
in the soviet system who would speak to
the general secretary of the communist
party
that way but reagan did it he did it in
speeches and he did it face to face
i want to tell you a joke that reagan
told
also face to face he loved jokes he knew
a million jokes
he used jokes sometimes just to relax
people
but other times to carry a message
he told gorbachev the following story
the communist party in moscow passes a
new law
no speeding by anyone
none no speeding now in russia then
in all of the very broad boulevards and
this is
this is true i think it's still true it
was certainly true in the soviet days
and i saw it myself the two inner lanes
the middle lanes
were only for the use of limousines for
party big shots
so they could speed off to meetings or
to their cottages in the countryside
only they were allowed to use those
lanes so the day after this
ordinance is adopted reagan says
two moscow policemen are standing on
their beat
and they're standing on their corner and
a big limousine in one of those two
lanes
zips by and one of them says whoa
look at that that guy's speeding i'm
getting on my motorcycle i'm going to go
after him give him a ticket
and the second policeman says are you
crazy
that's got to be some communist party
big shot
you're going to get fired if you stop
you get fired you might get shot
don't do it oh the first belief and says
no no
the party just passed this law no
speeding by anyone the party said
i'm going to chase him down and give him
a ticket
now in that limousine was
michael gorbachev reagan says
he'd been at his dasha outside of moscow
when there was an emergency and he got a
phone call he said
come back to the kremlin so he rushes
outside to his limousine
and says to his driver i'm going to
drive you get in the back seat
as they enter moscow the cop pulls up
alongside
but five minutes later he returns to
that corner where he was standing with
his
with his friend and the second cop says
well did you give the guy a ticket
no oh why the second one says did you
couldn't catch up with him
no the first one says i i caught up with
him so the second well so why don't you
give him a ticket
anyway was it the first one says well
i'll be honest with you
i was afraid to give him a ticket
i got scared see i don't know who was in
there
but gorbachev was his chauffeur
everyone in the room laughed except
gorbachev
so the second part of reagan's winning
the cold war
the attack on communism and the third
his belief in america
he rebuilt our faith in our own country
vietnam had been a terrible defeat but
the worst part
was that so many americans thought it
had been a crime that we'd been on the
wrong
side reagan would have none of that not
after the
boat people in cambodia and the
massacres in vietnam
he re-moralized the vietnam war looking
backwards and he said quote
it is time we recognize that ours was in
truth a noble cause
again widely attacked but he didn't care
a few lines from his first inaugural
should convey this
freedom and the dignity of the
individual have been more available and
assured here than in
any other place on earth we are not as
some would have us believe
doomed to an inevitable decline
i do not believe in a fate that will
fall on us no matter what
we do that was the center of his message
now i've conveyed the sense that he won
the cold war you know there are a lot of
people who
would say no
gorbachev gorbachev should get the
credit for ending the cold war
in 1990 as it does every 10 years time
magazine
named a man of the decade where now it's
person of the decade but in those bad
old days was
man of the decade who is the man of the
decade
mikhail gorbachev not ronald reagan
now i think gorbachev does get some
credit he seems to have understood that
jig was up that there would be no more
soviet victories in the third world
their economy could not possibly compete
with ours he seems to have understood
that
we were spending four percent of our
gross national product on
defense he was spending 20.
so it's a you know significant thing
that he reaches those conclusions
but i'll just read you what a writer at
the
left of center slate magazine wrote at
some point some krebs
kremlin leader would have had to mount a
major reassessment
the soviet system was dysfunctional and
its empire was collapsing the cupboard
was bare
reagan's surging military budgets
without question
brought that internal crisis to a head
so i give some credit to gorbachev for
seeing sooner what another soviet leader
would have
seen later but as our friend at slate
magazine wrote
if reagan hadn't been president if jimmy
carter or
walter mondale had defeated him this is
a guy who's a left-wing democrat writing
this
or if reagan had died or if george h.w
bush had taken his place then
gorbachev would almost certainly not
have received the push or reinforcement
that he needed
it's an interesting thing reagan
go back to that word reinforcement the
reinforcement gorbachev needed to begin
to make those changes
because reagan wasn't looking for soviet
surrender he wasn't trying to demolish
them
the soviet foreign minister said that
behind reagan's program quote
lies the clear calculation the uss
horrible exhausted material resources
and be forced to surrender but he wasn't
looking reagan wasn't looking for
surrender
he was looking remember that quote from
notre dame to transcend
the cold war and the ussr and move on to
something better
move on above all to peace
in 1961 nikita khrushchev the soviet
dictator said we will
bury you but reagan wasn't trying to
bury the soviets he was trying to
free them from the oppressive communist
system
and turn the soviet union into something
better so gorbachev found himself
negotiating not with a vicious enemy
but with a hopeful man who thought a
better world
could be built and this too was one of
reagan's
great contributions to ending the cold
war reagan understood
all of this just after reagan left the
white house gorbachev came to
the united states he was a great
celebrity
he was given feasts and dinners and
receptions all over the place especially
on the left but pretty much all over the
place
because he was given credit for ending
the cold war soul credit he did it
for reagan that was just fine
soon after leaving office a conservative
friend said to him
all that credit to gorbachev isn't that
a little
unfair and reagan replied
i don't resent his popularity good lord
i once co-starred with errol flynn
reagan i would say was the
was the author of the end of the cold
war he probably would have said he was
the screenwriter
and he was the the star he came to
office with a vision
he lived thank god to see that vision
achieved i want to commend hillsdale for
doing this centenary
because all this should be remembered
and studied and celebrated there is such
a thing
as a great man there are such things as
great ideas
love of country and dedication to it and
to its ideals should always be
celebrated i had the pleasure and the
honor last
week of meeting with former president
george w bush
in washington and someone at the meeting
thanked him for his service
to our country and bush replied no
i don't deserve thanks no one needs
thanks
for serving the country he loves
i'm sure president reagan would have
given the same answer
but i don't agree with it
at this centenary you remember ronald
reagan
and as americans we can all give our
thanks for the services
he performed for our country he loved
america and he served it always
with good cheer so let's use this
occasion to recall the
ideals he cherished and the good cheer
with which he worked
and keep them in our minds as models for
all of us to follow
thank you very much
thank you thank you very much
now now we have time for a
q a period and i think we're supposed to
give preference to students
so let's see some hands
um for those of us who were born months
and years after the fall of the berlin
wall
and who perhaps don't have the same
understanding of
fear that pervaded the country could you
please describe for us
the tensest or scariest moment in the
reagan administration
well in some way the the tensest and
worst and most horrible moment was the
day president reagan was shot
because you know here you have this man
who's now
one knocked out a president become
president we're in his first year in
office
things are just getting started there
are a lot of offices that haven't even
been filled yet
and then this horrifying thing comes
across
the wires the president's been shot
and as you know it was a very serious
wound and there were
there was some time when when it was
really not clear he was going to survive
although if you read about that day the
amazing thing and i think the thing that
that won him the hearts of americans who
had not voted for him
was again this amazing courage and um
and good cheer for those of you who are
too young to remember this
as he was wheeled into the operating
room he looked up from the gurney
and said to the doctors i hope you
people are all republicans
this is a man who's just been shot you
know it's just fantastic
i would say in addition to that the
marine barracks
um the day that that
all those americans were killed is just
an
absolutely horrifying day um beirut
lebanon
um in many ways that i would say those
were the
probably the two worst days
thank you very much mr aprons um
you managed to give an hour talk without
um saying what your role
or what you added to the reagan
administration and i believe it says
here
you are the assistant secretary of state
um could you talk a little bit about how
you helped with uh bringing down of the
soviet union
sure actually i only talked for about 35
minutes
i had a whole hour and i got into it um
well i actually had in the first year i
was assistant secretary handling
un affairs and i didn't
like that job a lot so i switched and
for the next three years this is the
first term was assistant secretary for
um
human rights which was promotion of
human rights that was a very
fun job and there was a view on the
american left that
president carter believed in human
rights president reagan you know
what conservatives are like they don't
believe in human rights so it was great
fun
to kind of draft up a series of
documents
about reagan human rights policy
and in fact what president reagan did in
those years is just extraordinary
because if you start in 1980
all latin america is military dictators
with
the only exception then costa rica and
venezuela everybody else
and all around the world lots of
dictators and
by the time reagan left office most of
the generals were gone in latin america
the others were on their way out they're
almost gone
democracy was coming to taiwan and the
philippines and south korea
and he did it by saying to them
basically you know
you have served a great role in
stopping communism and now you need to
step aside
because now you're becoming the problem
and he did it with ferdinand marcos he
got him to walk away from the from the
philippines
uh he did it time after time uh the
second term i was assistant secretary
for latin america
which which is central america and south
america
and those were the days of the in south
america of
getting rid of the generals which was
very uh
a wonderful task in central america we
had
war basically we had the
war in nicaragua above all and to a
lesser extent
in honduras and el salvador and a lot of
my time was spent working with the
nicaraguan contras
trying to beat the sandinistas and
ultimately
they were forced into an election which
happened the year after we uh
we left office and it was
the greatest fun of all actually was
when there would be a foreign visitor a
president from one of the latin american
countries uh because they'd come see the
president so then i would
go in and do a what we call the
pre-brief of the president
getting ready for uh for this visit and
then we'd do the visit and then we would
do
a meeting after the visit to figure out
what had uh
what had happened i guess i should tell
you one story about that
while i was doing that with
president reagan and president so and so
the wives would also meet nancy reagan
would give
a tea these were in those days there
were no women presidents in latin
america
so nancy reagan would give a tea for the
wife of president so-and-so
and who who would attend it my wife
the wife of the president obviously
nancy reagan and the wife of the u.s
ambassador to that country
and my wife told me this story at one of
those meetings when
uh the tea took place this foreign
president's wife
left and it was time for my wife and the
ambassador's wife
to take and secretary schultz's wife to
take their leave
of mrs reagan the ambassador's wife
had this ambassador had worked for eight
years in four years
in the previous administration been
appointed by the previous president
and as they took their leave this
ambassador's wife said
bye mrs carter
and secretary schultz's wife turned to
my wife and said
it's the end of his career
it wasn't because reagan was fair it was
a great story though
oh yes
thanks again for your speech i'd like to
know if you could
uh speak about china modern-day china
and
whether you think that they represent a
similar threat
today to what the ussr did in the
in the mid 80s
it's a very interesting and uh difficult
question
it's not the same threat in my view
the cold war was really a struggle for
world domination
and it brought us to the edge of nuclear
war several times
of course the cubanism crisis being the
worst and
we fought the soviet union i mean
we lost 50 000 men very roughly in korea
and another 50 000 in vietnam
so the price of the cold war was
enormous we don't have that kind of
war with china we have a rivalry with
china
i tend to be reasonably optimistic about
it
because i just don't believe that
communism will survive
in that country they're beginning to
move away from a command economy to a
free economy
i think that chinese are i think we see
already chinese more and more
demanding their rights
if you look at things like
strikes or
little rebellions in in towns or
villages against the local mayor or
local party boss
there are hundreds of thousands of these
already every year
i think that's going to increase so i
also don't see the chinese as
as being as great a a an economic threat
to us
because i think their system is not
going to make it and their demography
is awful remember they had for about 15
years this so-called one-child
policy which held down the number of
babies and particularly
the number of female babies
so now what you have is a population
that's aging
fast much much faster than the us
and you have this historically
anomalous imbalance between men and
women which is going to be devastating
to that
society as it would be to any so i
i think they're a very serious rival but
i have faith
in us
thank you so much for speaking with us
um you were mentioning the
american decline happening in the 70s
and i'm wondering if you think we are
currently experiencing a similar sort of
decline
based on the obama administration's
policy and behavior
with foreign heads of state and if so
what should the response to that be of
you know if we win the white house in
2012 or you know in the future what
should that
that president's response be well you
know
at one level i have an easy answer to
that question because i'm a republican
so you know the answer is to get a new
president
i think leadership counts for a lot i
think that
if you have a president president carter
let's say
who actually thinks that we're in the
middle of an american decline and that's
fine that's that's
not a bad thing it's a good thing
because as we go around the world we
just make trouble
anyway we intervene
that's a formula for decline and it kind
of demoralizes the american people
i think we're seeing some of that now
i think you you have to have leadership
that fights that now
look we have very serious problems
obviously we have a huge fiscal
problem in washington but it is not
a problem that that is uh insoluble
um i really think the the and
obviously there are plenty of
republicans to be blamed here too but
i really think there is a leadership
problem
um you know president nixon was
impeached he is followed by gerald ford
who is defeated after a couple years in
office
he is followed by jimmy carter who is
defeated after his
four years in office and if you go back
to the kind of conventional wisdom of
the day you know time newsweek
what were they writing our system
doesn't work
no one is fit to be president the
presidency is larger than any individual
what turned out we just had the wrong
guys and when we got the right guy
ronald reagan all of a sudden the system
works so i
i think leadership is absolutely
critical here if we're going to deal
with it with the real problems we have
do you want to hold on for the mic
thank you you said the beginning of your
speech that you were one of the many
americans who switched from being a
democrat to a republican to vote for
reagan
uh would you explain what it was that
reagan said or did that caused you to
change your opinion what the specific
issues were
it actually wasn't reagan as much as it
was carter
and there's actually a story here it's
worth telling
in in 1976 um
he's elected i was working for senator
henry m jackson scoop jackson of
washington a
conservative democrat um carter gets
elected
and does what a lot of us i i was in a
group with admiral zumwalt jean
kirkpatrick
um people like that and and
we were obviously drifting away and
walter mondale was vice president
wanted to keep all of us in democratic
party
so in 1980 this would be about
may june he said all of you should come
in
and meet with president carter
and this would reaffirm your loyalty to
the democratic party so we all went in
to see the president
and mondale met with us first in the
cabinet room there are about a dozen of
us
and he gave a terrific pitch
and all of us were sort of thinking well
i don't know
you know we've been democrats and then
the president came in the room
and we had agreed that one of us would
be the spokesman and he said mr
president you give us a great honor to
meet with us
we want to support you and remember this
is um
soviets invaded afghanistan in 1979
and he said we want to support you and
while it's true that we
we were very critical of your foreign
policy
since the soviet invasion of afghanistan
we do think the
policy has changed and toughened up and
we're
hopeful that we'll boom president carter
interrupted him
and said i don't have two foreign
policies i have the same foreign policy
i had
from the beginning
so that was the end of our speeches and
uh the president stayed about 15 minutes
which was probably
long enough to tell him what he needed
to know about us and vice versa
and as we all left that meeting every
one of us
shook our heads and said to the others
reagan
that was the moment that did it
thank you for the speech i am a uh
former republican due to disillusionment
during the reagan years
as a kid i went door-to-door for ronald
reagan in a blue-collar neighborhood i
just about got killed by all the
democrats there
but the big disappointment of the reagan
years i'd like you to comment on
big disappointment for me were the three
appointments that he made to the supreme
court only scalia
stands as a fine choice it seems that
the o'connor appointment was squandered
and it seemed that the bork appointment
was fantastic
but the great communicator failed to
make the case
to the american people and to get them
on the court so i think
i think two out of three liberals is a
bad record and democrats don't make that
mistake there's not one hard
conservative on the court that
the democrats didn't know was a
conservative tilly until he got there so
if you could comment on that
well first i think your facts are right
that is that democrats have a better
record of
always appointing a liberal and
republicans do have always appointed a
conservative and there are other
examples
president ford appointed john paul
stevens
president george h.w bush appointed
david suter
so this happens repeatedly
and
one of the reasons why has got to be
the desire to get an appointment through
what was in those days a democratic
senate
so you choose someone who appears to be
moderate
i think that's a mistake but i think
that's one of the things that goes into
the minds of
the political guys in an administration
um in the case of suitor
and president the first president bush
he was sold a bill of goods i think
frankly by his chief of staff
john sununu who was from new hampshire
and said you like him he's a
conservative guy
that was just wrong um
with bork the tragedy is
he appointed scalia as i recall and then
bork and if it had been bork and then
scalia
the president was stronger earlier on
and i think he would have gotten the
bork
appointment it would have been a
brilliant justice
but i it may have been i mean it looks
as if it was impossible then
once the democrats frankly led by
senator kennedy made a decision to just
go all out to
to smear judge borg
president bush made this mistake or may
have made this mistake
too he certainly didn't in the people
who got on the court he may have made
the mistake with harriet myers we'll
never know
because she had no judicial record
whereas
john roberts and samuel alito both had
records that
from the bush point of view you could
look at and say i know exactly the kind
of judge he is
but there's a real lesson here and and
it's the lesson you're
pointing to um we if you believe in
strict construction
as all of the current republican
candidates say they do
um you cannot take a chance on this this
is a lifetime appointment you've got to
have i would say
a judge my own opinion you've got to
have somebody who's been
a judge so that there's an there's a
real track record
as a judge or you run the risk that that
you're going to get what unfortunately
president reagan got
thank you so much
you must be a senior
this is a centenary celebration
i would like your comments on
how you i mean we have seen over the
years the assessment of the historians
back and forth on the reagan years i
mean i know you
are totally supportive i'm totally
supportive
what do you see is the academic
atmosphere
presently about the reagan years
it's a lot better than it used to be
this happened with president eisenhower
too most academics if you go to
1960 were saying that eisenhower
resisted dope
it began about five years after that a
man
professor named fred greenstein wrote a
book called the hidden hand presidency
that said if you think eisenhower was a
dope you are a fool
and began the reassessment of
eisenhower's extremely deft presidency
so reagan had a little bit of that
benefit now the academic left of course
hated him
but it's coming around already and
you begin to see more and more um
books and articles about him that say
that are the kind of
well of course i didn't agree with him
but
i didn't like him but i didn't vote for
him but
there's an acknowledgment now of his
fantastic skills as a
communicator there's also i think much
more of an appreciation of his mind
because the the view of many on the left
then was well he's a great communicator
he was an actor but he hasn't there's
nothing in there
but now we've seen his diaries and we
know that for decades
he was writing down thoughts and
analyses and comments about
world affairs now people begin to
appreciate
um what he was like
i hope ultimately this benefits
president bush
too but i'll leave you with with with a
with a story
it's hard to for academics i think to
fully appreciate
reagan they appreciate him a lot more
now than they used to
but one of the reasons is because he
like many politicians
had a sense about people
that doesn't show up on paper but that
you need to have to be a great
leader story the
leading industrial countries in those
days the g7 met in venice for their
summit and it was a good summit
and we had the next one the following
year
and as reagan and schultz are flying
back from venice
reagan said to schultz well george
where next this turned out to be the
williamsburg summit in williamsburg
virginia
he said we're next and we're going to
have the best summit
of all and schultz thought well you know
pep talk right and he said yes sir mr
president
and reagan said no no no no george
during this summit i have been watching
the other
presidents and prime ministers
and i have been asking myself when are
they
pleased and when are they displeased
when do they think they have had a good
and useful session and when do they
go away annoyed and frustrated and the
answer
he said to schultz the answer is
they like the sessions where they get to
talk a lot
not a great shock no one had ever said
this before and he said george
you may not like this but here's what i
want you to organize the williamsburg
summit
i want a lot of sessions
of leaders only i want seven of us in
the room so that we can have a lot
of conversation i do not want sessions
where the prime ministers
and the finance ministers and the
foreign ministers
and so forth chiefs of staff are in the
room i don't want
meetings with 40 people in the room that
is how they organized the williamsburg
summit
and reagan was exactly right and all the
other leaders went away from that summit
saying
wow we've never had this good summit
we've never been able to communicate
with each other
and discuss the problems we face more
openly
more candidly reagan figured that out
because one of the things that he was
doing as
president in addition to
thinking about the problems that he had
to solve
was looking at the man or in the case of
margaret thatcher the woman
sitting at the other end of the sofa or
across the table who is this person
what makes this person tick what do i
need to do
to get this person to give me what i
want for the united states
it's an enormous talent it's the talent
of a great great
politician and i think it's going to be
a while before
all of the memoirs are fully digested
and academics realize
but we are i would say we're halfway
there and the picture of ronald reagan
that they were giving in 1989
is is already really pretty much gone
and uh
i'm grateful for that and i'm confident
that he will be regarded
for ending the cold war and for many
other things as one of our greatest
presidents thank you very much it's been
a pleasure to be with you tonight
you